members I think it's how possible starts
members
okay uh good evening everybody uh
welcome to licensing appeals committee
21st of July before we start someone's
going to read the emergency evacuation
announcement should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the room by the same door you came
in turn right after the main doors into
the car park which is the assembly point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by Council staff
please note this meeting is being audio
recorded and can we make sure our mobile
is rather switched off or switched
silent
members when I invited to speak please
ensure you have one of the microphones
in front of you before speaking as
microphones are needed for the hearing
Loop and for the audio recording
these should all be switched on okay
already
um if you just speak so do not adjust
them please make sure that the
microphone is directly in front of you
before speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands this evening in line with the
Constitution I will ask for a show of
hands four and then against
recommendations those abstaining from
voting will be noted by officers
okay so I just wanted the agenda this
evening is apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
counselors Daniel FD Eileen Gadsden
Michael Hoy Tracy Knight Joe McPherson
Gary Myers David Sharp and Laureen Shaw
any other apologies that we need to make
a note of members
no
two substitute members we have counts
the sparing substituting for Council
Lorraine Shaw councilor Vilma Wilson
substituting for councilor Tony Carter
and councilor Christine Mason
substituting for councilor Michael Hoy
welcome to three any other substitutes
item number three no members attending
I don't think there are any other no
okay item number four uh minutes held
and the meeting on the 18th of January
2022 which had been circulated but I'm
aware that the only person around this
table who was at that meeting
is councilor Williams
so we were looking at you do you agree
them
I agree okay thank you
item number five is to receive
decorations of Interest any Declarations
of Interest members
okay none
okay now we come to the main businesses
of the evening item number six which is
a proposal for an increase to the
Hackley Carriage tariff by reducing the
yardage
Council council's principal licensing
officer Stephen Greeno will present the
report and
um
and karisbrook is also here licensing
officer if any questions need to be
asked of her so over to you Steve
good afternoon thank you very much uh
this is a report in proposed for an
increase to the Hackney Carriage tariff
by reducing the yardage I'll go through
it as much as I can because it is quite
technical that it still refers to yards
rather than meters and we'll try and
work away for it uh the licensing team
have received an application from the
licensing trade to change the current
Hackney Carriage tariff that has been in
place since April 2017.
in accordance with the local government
miscellaneous Provisions act the
licensing team have followed due process
and consulted with the trade and the
public over the proposals
and the final stage of the process is to
obtain support from the members to
support or reject the proposal
points two of the report outlines the
proposed chart as to what they would
like to include and that is to maintain
the current starting fare which is
currently at three pounds to remain as
it is
to reduce the yardage from 203 pounds
203.83 yards
to 175 yards until it reaches 8 pounds
on the meter
then after eight pounds on the meter
reduce the yardage to
152. oh reduce
yeah from
152.93 yards to
142 yards after the eight pound and also
as well to reintroduce the spoilage
charge of a hundred pounds which
basically covers the cleaning of the
vehicle and the loss of earnings
all other fees are to remain the same
the reason for the proposed increase has
been set out in appendix a in the
document that is in the report but the
main sort of points that they have
highlighted relates to the increases in
the cost of running a taxi increases in
general inflation comparisons with other
Transportation costs increases and the
affordability to the customer compared
to average wage increase
what I have done is within the report I
have tried to break it down a little bit
easier for you on the following page on
on page 6.2 as to what the current fair
is what the proposed fare is and the
difference
the main points really is
um the starting fare doesn't change
after one mile there'll be a 20p
increase uh three miles it's a pound
increase four miles it's one pound
twenty and 15 miles is three pound
I've also included as part of appendix B
is the flow chart in the process that we
have to follow following the decision of
the committee here that we then ask for
it to go to full Council for their
approval and then we have to legally
advertise it for 14 days before it takes
effect
on the 7th of April 2022 the licensing
team sent an email to all the Hackney
Carriage drivers of The Proposal
with the end of the consultation as
being the 6th of May 2022 and postal
returns by the 12th of May 2022.
the survey was sent to 247 drivers 34 of
the drivers responded so it was 85
drivers the results showed that 94.1
percent of the drivers supported the
increase and 5.9 percent of the drivers
did not feel that they could support it
based on this result the survey was then
taken on to the next stage which was the
public survey
The public's consultation started on the
13th of May 2022 with a press statement
by the council's communications team and
the consultation concluded on the 15th
of June 2022
to allow the minimum 30 days
requirements within the legislation
during that consultation period the
council received eight responses from
members to the public and a copy of the
consultation that was sent out is also
part of appendix C
the survey found that three of those
that had responded to the fair increase
supported the fair increase and five
people did not support the change
3.11 really highlights the comment that
came back and that was in my experience
Russia's TAXI fares are already more
expensive than similar adjoining
districts especially when considering
late night surcharges taxes are vital
for the elderly community and as such a
challenging time with the current cost
of living this in my view is completely
inappropriate
that leads me nicely onto 5.1 which is
the breakdown of the authorities based
on the documentation issued by the
private hire and taxi magazine we
provide those figures to them on a
monthly basis and this is a snapshot of
where we are within Essex
city is the most expensive within the
county
Two Mile Fare and rotches as you can see
sits roughly in the middle at seven at
six pounds 20. if the proposed fare
increase was to go ahead it will go to
six pounds 60 that will bring us in line
with Brentwood and Harlow
I've also included some documentation to
assist you with making decision and 5.3
is the petrol prices that have been
issued by the office of national
statistics so this is based on figures
that they control and it's a overall
figure across the whole of the UK from
the major operators
as you can see at the time of me writing
the report the field cost was
190
198.93 for diesel and
190.93 for unleaded petrol as you can
see from the charts it has had a
significant increase oh certainly over
the last sort of 12 months
on the next page I've also included the
CPI or Consumer Price Index figures
again that have been issued by the
office of national statistics that show
that obviously the
the Consumer Price Index has also seen a
significant increase as well
I'm going to draw your attention to
paragraph six of the report and a
previous Fair increase applications an
application was made by the trade on the
1st of July 2020
um where they
um were then at the time refused the
proposal and then they submitted a
further application in October 2021 and
the trades proposed at the time
a increase to maintain the current
starting fare and to reduce the yardage
at their time to 186 yards
from the 203 yards and to reduce after
eight pounds to
142 where it's currently 152.93
in relation to the proposal I'll jump to
that if that's okay that the application
by the trades to be determined for a
fair increase as outlined in appendix a
to this report taking into account the
representations received and the
contents of this report if the committee
is minded to approve the proposed
increase
that it be agreed to the implementation
date of the increases to be delegated to
the assistant director of people and
communities includes consultation with
the portfolio holder for licensing and
that this will be no later than the end
of August 2022 and that's the end of the
report
thank you Stephen uh members so we've
heard the report
um with any questions any members like
to ask any questions about them council
Mrs Mason
[Music]
yes thank you chair I'd just like um to
ask three questions
um if I may that
um and forgive me if they're in the
report I did read it a few days ago and
I might have missed it
um the number of licenses that we have
issued and how do they relate to the
number of licenses that say we had in
July 2019 predict pandemic
have we got any knowledge of that we do
we saw a 30 reduction in drivers because
of kovid
in the end of last year we bought a
report to the licensing committee that
we identified so that was a significant
problem with the lack of drivers being
out there certainly on a Friday and
Saturday night certainly with
safeguarding issues around individuals
so at that time we introduced a scheme
called the earn as you learn scheme
which has allowed us to reduce the time
period it takes for taxi drivers to get
out there initially so what we do is we
issue them they have to complete the
same checks as everyone else apart from
the stumbling block that they have which
is the knowledge test which takes
approximately about three to six months
for them to pass obviously anyone coming
into that trade if they know that they
can't work for three to six months then
we're going to struggle with bringing
that sort of the drivers into the trade
so what the committee agreed was that
they could do a fast track system or the
earners you learn providing they met the
same requirements that we have in place
for private hire drivers
um then we could issue them with a badge
for a period of nine months and during
that nine month window that they can
then work but also learn the roads and
the routes so that they can then take
their Knowledge Test within that nine
month window if they do take it within
that nine month window then we switch
the badge over to a Hackney Carriage
badge if they don't complete it in that
nine month window then they have to
reapply for a new badge after 12 months
that scheme has worked really really
well we brought it in in January we've
had two drivers so far that have
completed all the way through and been
issued their Hackney Carriage badge we
have
I had the figures only the other day I
think it's 26 drivers that we've issued
um that are out there under the earners
you learn and we have 19 new applicants
currently going through at the moment so
we are backing the trend compared to the
rest of the county and what I can then
show you nationally the figures have
shown that we've got a decrease whereas
Roger had actually seen an increase yeah
can I just come back on that Mr chairman
you said 30 decrease but 30 of what uh
it was roughly
it was
300 and
20
320 drivers we had pre-covered so we've
lost about 90 and we've got about on
your figures 30 about 45 coming back so
far yeah so so we're 50 there thank you
so I've got two other questions if I may
Mr chairman
um you've given us some chance of the
increase of the yardage and the effect
it has on the
pricing on 3.2 I believe it will be on
page 6.2
is there anywhere in the report I hate
to ask this because I should have worked
here myself but I haven't what is the
percentage increase roughly in pound
Shillings and Pence I know what you're
saying
um 10 pound goes to 11.20 but when it
comes to the uh which is relatively easy
to work out but when it comes to the
other you've got the percentage you've
got the difference how much it's in
pounds Shillings and pounds but bearing
in mind the other figures that we've
been given are in percentage increases
is there any way that we can have a
rough idea of the percentages that they
will increase by I'll quickly do some
mass calculations
the screen suddenly change a bit
thank you and perhaps
brilliant thank you
I think I think it just happened after
the first eight pounds yeah
that's feel free no no it's very helpful
without a calculator
thank you and I think that helps put it
in perspective and the other thing I was
quite interested to note in your report
that you say that you supply figures on
a monthly basis till the taxi or the
Hackney Carriage to the magazine yes to
the magazine
have you always done that and are those
figures readily available yes okay thank
you thank you Mr chairman I would
probably like to speak later but the
moment that's my questions answered
thank you thank you Mrs Mason cuts
across
um thank you Mr chairman
um
one of the complaints or the complaint
was about a late night surcharge and I
can't see that addressed anywhere so can
you tell us what the late night
surcharge is please I can yes the extra
charges I'll read them now because I've
got the the direct Fair table in front
of me here
um for hiring beginning between 10 30 pm
and 6 A.M
also on Sundays and bank holidays
between 6 a.m and midnight there is a
additional fee of two pounds is added to
the starting fare
so after 10 30 at night the starting
Fair starts at five pounds rather than
three pounds okay also on Sundays and
bank holidays but the actual rates per
yard doesn't change no no the only time
it does change is on Christmas day sorry
the hire begins at 9 00 pm on the 24th
of December and 6 a.m on the 27th of
December and between 9 p.m on the 31st
of December and 6 a.m on the 2nd
December is double fares
some supplementary question if I might
or an additional question rather
um all of the comparisons have been uh
taken at two miles I don't know whether
that's a an average Journey but bearing
in mind the the initial charge is is the
higher proportion I'd like to have seen
some comparisons at say four miles
six miles 10 miles which are I think
quite common sort of distances as well
yeah um I don't have that information
um like I say it's all published by the
the magazine so I've literally just
picked out all of our councils out of
the the appendix d ross is very very
back
um yeah that's
that should have been included
um I haven't got the other Fair tables
unless I can
I might be able to quickly pull up a
couple of others that while I've got a
computer or an internet connection I
might be able to do a few bits there for
you to give you some figures if you give
me some time to work on that thank you
Stephen I think that would be useful to
to look at thank you okay
close enough
council Mrs Bell
and just
points regarding the percentages I think
they
20ps five percent roughly of four pound
forty and four pound is about eight
percent so just so that we don't have
any crossed wires if we can just pull it
up on the calculator just so that we're
all clear
um I'll be honest having read the report
I'm in full support of this increase
there's never a good time to increase
prices but there's also never a good
time to not have your wages increased
and when the cost of living is going up
for everybody and so having read all of
the details of the report and giving it
thought on both sides I really think
after five years of no increase it's
it's viable we're seeing a lot of taxi
drivers we're seeing taxi drivers become
delivery drivers we're seeing a real um
reduction although we're gradually
starting to increase that again I think
we all if anyone's tried to get a taxi
in the last six months they'll know how
challenging it is in comparison to
pre-covid and so personally I I'm in
favor of this increase I don't think
they're asking for an awful lot when you
look at the percentages which to my
loose maths was about five to eight
percent overall fuel costs have gone up
dramatically
um I I think it's reasonable I think
it's a reasonable request and I think
five years of no change is long enough
in in my opinion I appreciate I'm new to
licensing but based on the report that
I've read and the consultations that
I've seen online for the past year or so
I think this is a reasonable
um request thank you
thank you
um I'm aware that council Mrs Mason and
Council cross wish to speak I'm just
going to give other members a chance
first that's okay councilor Williams
thank you chairman
I've really got concerns over this um
we're having bus routes cut in Rochford
we're now down to I think it's from July
three number sevens an hour
um I'm not sure how many is on the
number eight route but the number eight
route is going completely on a Sunday
so local residents will have to use if
they don't drive a taxi or they'll stay
indoors
um I do have serious concerns about
especially for retired people pensioners
on a fixed budget they can't increase
their income I
is there any way that this could be
index linked so that when fuel goes down
the cost of the increase goes down
uh it can be done in a way south end and
Castle Point have done it slightly
differently rather than see a general
increase what they have agreed is that
to add a extra surcharge onto the extras
area where they can charge an extra 40p
once the petrol prices reached a certain
stage that has to be approved obviously
by the assistant director for those
areas and also the portfolio holder and
they're using the same figures as what
we are which is the office of national
statistics so they monitor those and
then they authorize it for a set period
of time that that 40p increase could
then be used so the extra 40p overall
over on top of what is the the fare yes
all right thank you
yes for now thank you the council Sperry
listening to councilor belton's comments
I fully support them
um I also take on board what councilor
Williams has said about the the older
generation in the business that I'm
involved in a lot of the older
generation are entirely dependent on the
TAXI fares they are missing out on the
events now because there are not enough
taxi drivers now they're turning up hour
an hour late and these are regular
people who phone into the local taxi
companies they're well known they're not
getting any priority treatment they're
missing events and I just feel that if
we don't support this then we're going
to find we're going to go back to the
pre-covered days taxi drivers will look
for another area
delivery drivers and all this sort of
stuff because that business is
continuing to grow
and I just feel that we won't be doing
our residents any favors to be honest I
think they will just find that they will
be house effectively housebound because
there'll be no bus routes as you say and
they'll won't be able to get any taxes
because they just won't be available
thank you chairman
I think
because I've got no Tony uh councilor
this is Wilson
hello thank you
um I've been doing a bit of digging into
this because the the bit that fascinated
me the most or can certainly the most
whichever way you want to look at it was
actually the price of um
fuel going forward
because
um I do fully support this and feel that
the taxi drivers have had a really rough
deal recently and I was really surprised
when I read this that they've had no
increase for such a long while
um
the I've read two reports granted online
but both from very reputable
organizations that they reckon that with
what's going on in the world at the
moment that within the next six months
the best case scenario would be the
unleaded petrol would Reduce by a
maximum of 50 pence per liter
this report here on appendix they gives
the cost or gives the comparisons at 123
a liter well if fuel went down my 50
pence a liter that's a lot more than
this
and taxi drivers the same as the rest of
us have had cost of living
um issues to to deal with and that's
part of the reason why I support this
because even if fuel does decrease as
much as these reports that I've read
said it will it still won't really cover
the the um additional increases that tax
drivers will face
with what councilor Sperry said I think
we need to keep as many taxes in our
Borough as we can from our residents
Council weapon
just ask a question please around the
reintroduction of the spoilage charge
can I just ask how that works who makes
the decision if that will be applied
um because it's sort of thing I guess
could be open to abuse in terms of is
there a point at which it gets applied
and who would make the decision please
yeah that is down to the taxi driver if
someone is ill within a vehicle which is
what is the reason why it's mainly sort
of brought in for
um and they were sick in the vehicle
then obviously they would have to go and
get that vehicle cleaned and then that
just basically allows the taxi driver to
have the authority to show that there is
a spoilage charge that they can charge
of the maximum up to 100 pounds for them
to go and get the car cleaned while
they're also losing work as well
I'm gonna just check so just to clarify
that would only apply if somebody was
sick in the car it wouldn't apply if
somebody say spilled a drink in the back
of the car
um it wouldn't necessarily stop them
from operating and if I find that it was
that someone was charging 100 pounds for
a sport drinking the car then I would be
looking into that matter okay okay thank
you thank you
um I'm conscious there's two other
members wish to speak any other members
not spoken or wants to speak
council Mrs Mason
I take on board
um
Council
Williams concerns and as my world is
adversely affected by the failure of the
number eight bus route I share his
concern but we are concentrating on the
taxi service tonight and I think we have
to take buses somewhat out of the
equation
the concern I have and I must admit I I
support what council Belton sparing and
Wilson have said that
we have a problem we have a supply
problem this supply and demand
and if someone has a Hospital
appointment they need to be rely on a
taxi that will turn up at the moment
there's an inadequate Supply and I've
experienced it myself where taxes
haven't turned up even when book days in
advance
and the other thing that I've become
aware of is that I've spoken to some I
say young younger than me but in in
their 20s young ladies and girls that
would normally go out at night
and they're not going out at night
because they can't be sure getting a
taxi back and they consequently feel
unsafe so there's a knock-on effect to
the nighttime economy as well so I do
support this however
I I am concerned that it's been five
years
and although we have looked at this I've
seen that 20 and 21 I'd like to
formalize that
and for that reason I'd like to put a
motion forward that hopefully will be
supported that this committee
Implements of regular review either
annually or biannually I prefer annually
but if the committee chairman prefers
annually fine of the Hackney Carriage
tariff taking into account
increases in decreases in fuel prices
inflation rates and other criteria is
deemed appropriate with effect from the
2023 Municipal year because I am
concerned that having seen this we've
had an application in 2012 we had an
application in 2017. we had one in 2020
which was refused one in 21 and now from
October 21 we're talking about August 22
that I do think the committee should be
looking at this on a regular basis so I
would like to propose that if I have a
second just before you Mr Cas Mrs Mason
before you get the second uh can I just
check with Steve that because I know
that's not the norm legis legislation
permits us to do that
um we would still follow the same
process that we would still put it out
for the drivers for the consultation and
then the public consultation that
doesn't preclude us from reviewing it
right thank you thank you Mrs there's
nothing that precludes usually
um it's really to consider the
effectiveness for this committee to look
we've just heard it you know we've lost
effectively 45 plus drivers so this
committee could consider the
effectiveness of any increase and
decrease in maintaining the level of
service provision in relation to demand
and that will allow perhaps us to be
preventing a problem rather than as we
are now curing a problem
so
that's my proposal
thank you Council Mr Mason does anybody
wish to second that motion
Cosmos Squires Coleman thank you members
we're now going to speak on the motion
that council Mrs Mason has moved and
councilor Mr Squires Coleman has
seconded does anybody any member wish to
speak on that particular motion alone
please
Council across thank you chair
um yes I'm wholeheartedly in agreement
with what councilman Mrs Mason has said
um I would like to see it as being every
two years
and I didn't want it misconstrued my
earlier questions that I wasn't in favor
of an increase to the taxi rate so I'm
very much in favor of that my questions
really were is this increase enough
because if we are only going to review
it every two years it needs to
preempt any increases I think this is
only just about recovering what's
already been lost so I was actually
pushing for a greater increase to take
it up nearer to to the
um you know the higher levels that are
on there perhaps not as much as uh
maximum one but um but yes I'm all in
favor of a biannual review thank you
Chad
I was leaving that because I thought it
would be then up to the chairs this
question so
no strong feelings one way or the other
I
any other member wish to speak on that
motion
I I I'd like to say one point actually
because um it was something I was going
to bring up when we were talking about
the main issue this evening and I
understand where Castle cross is coming
from with regards to the the catch-up I
think we all perceive there's a huge
catch up for two reasons one because
there's been a long delay since we last
did this so I actually support the
review and I will support this this
motion because I think it actually it is
right that we do this we do review it
not saying we put it up it's right that
we review it that we review it
um but looking at the charts on 5.3 on
page 6.4 there's a huge a very very
steep increase
um which uh is probably in line with the
invasion in Ukraine
um and so I think that's probably
distorted figures somewhat now we are
where we are the price of fuel is where
it is
um but I don't you know I'd like to
think that the world I'd like to Hope I
should say that the war in Ukraine is
going to come to an end at some points
and the fuel crisis will will revert
back to um it's it's its previous level
so I think that's distorted things
slightly
um but on that subject I um I do think a
review is is a good idea any other
members to speak on this motion before
bring cancer across back in that counts
across
just to say I think it's before the
invasion of Ukraine but it's it's I
would say directly linked to the value
of the pound against the dollar which
after brexit uh did plummet and oil is
paid for in in dollars per barrel so I
think it's in line with with the fall in
the value of the pound
for clarity again I think it would be
really handy uh
if you could just commit to a time scale
that you would um
no problem uh the the motion is that
this committee implements a regular
review biannually
and he carries tariffs taking into
account increases and decreases in fuel
prices inflation rates and other
criteria as deemed appropriate to
consider the effectiveness of any
increased decrease in maintaining the
level of service provision in relation
to demand refused to take effect from
the 2023 Municipal year
Mrs kraska are you still happy to
secondly okay
members you've heard the motion on the
table in front of you all those in favor
please indicate now
um that's unanimous thank you members
that motion is carried
members were now returned back to the
main discussion uh which is the report
in front of us item six
um
now I've still got Council cross on my
list of people wishing to speak on that
would you because you put your hand up
before I know you've spoken on council
Mrs Mason's motions you wish to speak
again or are you happy with you said
what you wanted to say good so thank you
does any other member wish to speak
on this this size I'm just going to say
one thing on this um I think this comes
down to um
two things really uh looking after the
taxi trade and looking after our
residence looking after our taxi trade
because we need to keep a taxi trade we
need to look after our our taxi drivers
um and and in a sense it was quite
interesting talking to Steve before this
meeting and he put it quite
um aptly the fact that in effect with
their employers and we're deciding their
wages and and that actually brings it
all to home really you know we talk
about um considering somebody's wages I
was quite shocked when I read this
report
um how long well my my initial thing I
think I didn't go to the like a typical
bloke I didn't go to the start of the
report I went halfway through and I
looked at the prices and I was quite
surprised by the price I thought why are
you asking for an eight to nine percent
increase in in prices when you know uh
train drivers aren't getting and other
people aren't getting it but actually
when you look at the the last time there
was an increase it's quite some time ago
and I think that puts it all into
perspective really I think the comments
have been made this evening about
keeping the trade alive are very very
valid I think the comments about looking
after the residents are very valid as
well
um because it does concern me about the
demographic people who do use the
um do use taxis but but personally I do
support this as well so if no one else
wishes to speak
I'm going to take this to the boat
members are you happy there's two
proposals before you I'm going to read
them out and then please indicate if
you're happy to take this on block if
anybody would like to take them
separately
so the recommendations before us so that
the application by the trade be
determined for a fair increase as
outlined within appendix a to this
report taking into account the
representation was received and the
contents of this report
if the committee is minded to approve
the proposed increase
that he'd be agreed that the implement
the implementation date of The increased
fares be delegated to the Assistant
Director people and communities in
consultation with a portfolio holder for
licensing and that there's been no later
than the end of August 2022
does any member wish to take these
recommendations separately if not I we
will take them on block
okay members you've heard the
recommendations for you all those in
favor please indicate
and that's unanimous those proposals are
carried thank you members
uh members that's the end of the uh
business for this evening and therefore
the time is now seven minutes past eight
and this meeting is close thank you very
much for attendance